[Music]
it's a rare sound these days a Roman
Catholic Mass said in Latin the language
was once at the heart of Western culture
for centuries most books and official
letters were written in Latin today it
is considered a dead language except to
those who are trying to resurrect it
brook silva-braga is here with one man's
efforts to keep Latin alive
Brooke good morning good morning well
one estimate puts the number of truly
fluent Latin speakers in the world at
just a hundred people but one man has
made it his life's work to save the
language from extinction and where he's
doing it is as unlikely as how he's
doing it in the basement of a nursing
home in Milwaukee the world's best Latin
lessons are given for free virginity
nearby in the middle of the table that's
father Reginald Foster you have to do
this sooner or later
Momo's a priest who lacks patience and
sure a teacher dominates his classroom
away the man who has managed to convince
hundreds of people sit loose to dedicate
their lives to a language no own living
his passion is what drives us
he's like the rock star of the Latin
world so it's just great to be in his
orbit why are you so good at Latin is it
just the time you put in you see where
I'm sitting on I but you sit on your
butt and study Latin as long as I am
you'll be a master too it just seems too
hard no every poor person derelict
prostitute anyone else in Rome it's
forgotten if they could do it well I
figure do it I also say when the Roman
said to their dogs dad pets come here
sit down and eat your dinner
vanie look conceding adheenam to armed
su-mei and take your dinner and Ladin
the dog Victor though as a young man
foster the son of a Milwaukee plumber
became a priest in Rome with a knack for
the language and in 1970 got a call from
the Vatican they wanted him to translate
Latin for the Pope for the next 40 years
he wrote speeches and letters in the
names of four popes pretend that you're
the Pope what would you say I said well
I have some ideas
one of Foster's ideas was rejecting the
trappings of the church instead of a
priest's habit he dressed like a working
man instead of a mattress he slept on
the floor his Latin was so good the
church tolerated foster but the high
profile job didn't quite satisfy him
upstairs in the office was useless it
was reading those letters so I said I
want to do something useful
she said glad in my way his way meant
scrapping the traditional method of
memorizing tables of text and instead
treating Latin as a living spoken
language it was a radical departure in
approach something out of the world of
fantasy a monk in Rome speaking Latin
Jason pedak own had studied Latin by
rote but never heard anyone speak it out
loud
he has scores of students who've become
Latin teachers several have become Ivy
League professors that has affected a
change on the culture of the way Latin
is taught foster would still be teaching
and translating at the Vatican if a bad
fall hadn't landed him in a wheelchair
just as an appearance in Bill Maher's
2008 documentary Religulous landed him
in hot water with the church Foster was
flown home to Milwaukee never to return
to Rome third chapter are these senses
now 78 he's working on textbooks to
share his method there I am 19 years old
but is devoid of sentiment we asked if
he had photos of his life and he said
he'd thrown them all in a dumpster years
ago luckily a neighbor climbed in and
saved them why would he throw all this
out this is the history of your life
and it's gone past finished oh it's done
forgotten goodbye
Toto just accept it isn't really
Foster's old students not only carried
on the Latin summer classes in Rome
Jason pedak owns non profit the Padilla
Institute now brings Latin into
underserved American classrooms open
these kids English vocabularies in the
process wait guys go guys guys guys guys
wait and on a recent Saturday high
school students swept through New York's
Metropolitan Museum of Art for a Latin
scavenger hunt the Gospel of father
Reginald Foster is winning converts how
long have you been studying out five
hundred and fifty seven days so she
won't forget race Milliman wrote the
date on her shoes in Roman numerals
number second 2016 and I walked into
that classroom and like my entire life
changed
people say it's a dead language it's
roaming around it's not dead you were
ready for that I am always ready seeing
a young person that excited even if he
doesn't want to admit it I think would
make Reginald really really happy and I
think that in her he will live on and
the tradition will live on it's not
right that's what you've tried to change
I am changing I'm really done
teachers know and foster is willing to
teach anyone who shows up in Milwaukee
no experience needed his method is also
taught in a London summer program and
his second book in that five volume
series is now headed to the printing
press and he says he has no plans to
stop teaching amazing it's Fugit carpe
diem yeah that's all I know I know he
said even a dog could learn it but I
took it all the way through high school
and it was murder he says people are
learning it the wrong way I think he's
probably right because it didn't work
for me Silva Braga thinks